well a new government report says
manmade climate change is already
wreaking havoc on the US and it will
only get worse in the coming decades the
report from 13 federal agencies warns of
more destructive Western wildfires
longer heat waves in the southeast and
more powerful Atlantic hurricanes it
says climate change could shrink the US
economy by hundreds of billions of
dollars by the end of the century Tony
Zucco poll is at a Midwest farm already
struggling with the effects he's in
Versailles Indiana Tony good morning
good morning well it might seem a little
bit odd to cover global warming while
standing in a heavy coat but here in the
Midwest the concern is not just about
higher temperatures but a large and
costly increase in precipitation what
you're looking at here is a field of
ruined soybeans too wet to harvest and
the farmer you're about to meet says
he's lost 20 acres this way all a
casualty he says of climate change
she's like chewing gum were just too wet
Jim Benham says he doesn't need a PhD to
know that things have changed when we
have a rain event we're not getting an
inch we're getting two and three and
four inches this year many of his
soybeans are too soggy to harvest they
turn to paste if he tried and what's
worse the 67 old farmer says all this
rain isn't just bad luck
he believes its climate change doesn't
take a scientist note you got a problem
that's what I'm experiencing and
scientists degree in the fourth National
Climate Assessment issued Friday 13
federal agencies warned climate change
will reduce Midwest agricultural
productivity two levels of the 1980s
Andrew light one of the reports editors
says evidence humans are causing climate
change is undeniable the part of the
country that's going to get worse
fastest is actually the mid midwest
where we're which is the breadbasket of
America the rest of the country doesn't
fare much better
report says sea levels around the u.s.
have risen about nine inches by 20 90
rising seas could cause a hundred and
eighteen billion in property damage
every year heat waves now last more than
40 days longer than they did in the
1960s by 2090 outdoor workers could lose
a hundred and sixty billion in wages
from extreme heat in 2015 wildfires
burned more than 10 million acres that's
larger than the state of Maryland as
recent wildfires like the camp fire have
left California devastated the report
warns of hotter drier conditions in the
west towards the end of the century you
could see the United States economy
losing hundreds of billions of dollars
every single year and tens of thousands
of Americans dying every single year
because of climate change this is all
avoidable at this point avoidable in
theory President Trump has said that
manmade climate change is a very
expensive hoax and last year he pledged
to pull the United States out of the
Paris climate Accords that's a global
agreement to actually do something to
slow global warming now the authors of
this report a report put out by the
Trump administration oddly enough say
that for every dollar spent addressing
that warming you can expect a savings of
three to seven dollars Nora that report
by many agencies has the science behind
it Tony thank you